I'm currently the business intelligence
team lead that uplift and this talking
about the solution that we Geyer and I
came up to a text similarity machine
problem so guys are you wanna you wanna
introduce oh well now
yeah like I'll do to the beginner so
yeah hi my name is layer yes like last
year I've been working in uplift and
I've been working with jurgis on that
particular problem and took a part as a
technical product manager and some
devops operations also like so it was a
bit weird project yes and I hope that
you'll like the talk sorry
before you start I forgot to say so the
speakers requested that we do all
questions in the end if you have any
questions you can send them in the chat
window and then we'll callate those and
go through as many as we have time for
don't interrupt the speakers please just
put them put the questions in the in the
chat window sorry good so here using
sort what we're going to talk about
today I'll start from where the problem
originated and then describe it and then
I'll jump to the way we try to solve it
and spend a bit more time on the final
at least for now solution then Gaia will
jump in to give some details regarding
the deployment we which he took care of
let's start with the motivation or in
other words where the problem came from
so even though my purpose is not to
explain uplifts a business model it's
essential to give you on one slide
overview of what we do so let's assume
you're an app developer with a new app
and since you spend so much valuable
time into developing it you not want
some you use in order to monetize in
this case uplift could be your community
because of the network of media partners
it has so this media partners have ups
with traffic and could potentially show
wads of you
up to users that would be interested in
it but you are a demanding client so and
you should be and you want transparency
in other words you want to know which
are the apps that are showing ads of
your valuable up so uplift is asking
media partners to post back all the apps
where your ad is being sold so media
partners are sending back the app ID and
what the app has in their corresponding
app store so Google Play or iTunes or at
least we can extract the app ID using
regular expressions and then the
matching and reporting the app view as a
client is easy but there are however
other media partners that are sending to
us only the app names
quite often without without the exact
same form that it has in the app store
but what we want to share with you as
our clients is official up IDs so not
the name only that is heard from the
media partner and this is the origin of
our problem we want to match the app
names that are sent to us by our media
partners let's call them dirty with
actual up names from the app stores
let's call them clean and for the sake
of this talk let's just consider the the
numbers for the Android apps
sorry allistic number of Android app
names that we would receive per day it's
about three thousand and there are
roughly nine million apps in Google Play
Store so that would give us 27 billion
combinations to to examine so before
going directly to the final solution we
thought it would be useful to also serve
part of the journey to sweet
so as you know as professional
developers we study from a very
non-conventional place Google and our
problem will be classified as an
approximate three string matching a
problem and after a bit of searching
this product to the Levenstein distance
as one of the ways to approach such
problems which is defined as the minimum
number of single character edits
required to change one word into another
we used our well tested technique to
search for such a targets in Python
fuzzy wuzzy came up and we did implement
fuzzy wuzzy forgiveness initially in a
quick way in Google collab notebooks on
the upper left corner there is a
reminder of the size of our problem
and so to compute the levenshtein
distance of only one entry from the
direct data set against all 9 million
entries from the clean data set or the
apps android apps coming from Google
Play Store took us about 10 minutes and
if you do the math for this that leads
us to about 21 days for trying to match
the food dirty data set to the clean one
which for such a problem we could say
that it is pretty much equal to eternity
so let's let's now see what we finally
or at least for now implemented we
started thinking about how input
significantly speed up set some awesome
process and I guess I do not have to
argue here that computers are fast into
performing and mathematical computation
the question pretty much was how can we
go from text to numbers well it seems
there are a lot of ways in literature to
do so one of the most famous ones for
vectorization a doctor ization is a term
for transforming text to vectors or at
least that that's how it's used here
tf-idf an abbreviated time frequency
invest document frequency to save some
time I won't give the exact definition
here but feel free to use the advanced
techniques presented before and by that
I mean Google to find out how how it is
defined
instead of so an example on the next
slide so I don't really like to show a
lot of coil in my presentations but I
made an exception here to show how easy
it is to do this vectorization using
scikit-learn after the import the whole
factorization is happening in three
lines so clean and dirty here are the
data sexes the data sets that contain
text and tf-idf matrix clean and tf-idf
matrix 30 are the vectorized versions of
them
the analyzer function here and Gramps
I'm going to explain is defined by us
and I'm gonna explain in the next slide
what it does so let's assume that our
clean data set has only two entries
Facebook and Instagram and before going
to the vectorization we need to define
the feature vector we we decide to take
all three consecutive letter
combinations of our clean data set and
that is what the analyzer function
engrams that we shown the previous slide
does once this is in place we can
transform our data set to a matrix which
has as many rows as may as as many the
entries of our clean data set and as
many columns as the size of our feature
vector you can see here you can see for
example that AC E is part of the word
Facebook and that's the number down here
in the vector is not zero it would be a
1 but the vector this this line that
that corresponds to the file to the
vector for Facebook is normalized so in
other words if it is a unit vector
similarly for example AG R is part of
the word Instagram and so the
corresponding entry in the vectorized
matrix contains a number and so on so
that's how we go from text to numbers or
to shed more more properly to two
vectors and having vectors available
instead of words allow us allows us to
play ball in a whole different field we
can now conveniently compare the vectors
instead of the words so let's take 2 2 D
vectors as an example well in reality
our vectors are of much higher
dimensionality and how big as much as
the size of our feature vector so an
easy way to compare two vectors how
close two vectors are is taking the
angle between them or compute the cosine
of the angle the smaller the angle gets
the more the concerned the cosine
approaches 1 so to compute the cosine of
the
we can use the dot product between the
two vectors which is equal to the cosine
of the angle since both of them are
normalized so there you that there are
unit vectors and after a bit of online
searching a well we found a very nice
package that does this in a very
efficient way
it's called sparse dot top m and if I
actually go back to the previous slide
here you'll see that in this matrix
there are a lot of there are a lot of
zeros
and yeah and other data set becomes the
clean data set becomes real and more
entries coming to it those zeros become
more and more forming a very very sparse
matrix so these these packets use a site
on to perform a very efficient sparse
matrix multiplication and it can also
select only results that are above a
certain threshold in the resulting
cosine matrix this means that we need to
save only the best matches so everything
that's matte is above a threshold like
let's say point seven from with for a
scale from zero to one and only keep
those which allows to save even more
space so everything that was described
so far was initially using pandas for
the implementation in Python and while
developing this guy I thought okay this
seems like a nice fish case for for dusk
I checked it out and in the end I
discovered the one more way to make this
a bit more efficient to make say it
simply does helps you paralyze
computation when using data frames
without changing matching to your code
so all the well-known function of pandas
scikit-learn an umpire are supported and
it can run locally taking advantage of
multiple CPUs or a distributed cluster
see some sample code using a dusk and
after the basic imports you can if you
want specify a cluster as a client and
from there you pretty much can use
almost anything you know in pandas by
just using VD here instead of instead of
PD
in case some other package you're using
does not support dusk you can always go
back and forth from and to bundys here
is the data flow of the whole algorithm
I just described so the clean the clean
and dirty data sets are being loaded
from bit way into the start frames
vente vectorization is happening using a
scikit-learn then we're using the matrix
that we the patterns that we discussed
to do the dot product and compute cosine
similarity matrix we extract the mattes
after this is done and then we
underscores of course the similarity
scores and then we load back to bigquery
a lookup table on the next slide you can
see a simple from from some of the real
up names that we actually matched I'm
giving you a second to to take a look
here and just for the record from this
original 21 days estimation formatting
the Android apps we went down to roughly
20 minutes and are now possible to
Geyer to speak about how he made the
deployment of this algorithm happen how
we made it deployment thanks ok so hi
everyone and he had like as Jurgis told
before definitely off to crunch that
amount of the data we needed something
really powerful and just deploying it
one virtual instance like wouldn't be
strong enough so all modern computation
like all modern like cloud management
management system like today using
kubernetes and we had already kubernetes
cluster deployed and we I was already
playing trying
to launch the airflow on our managed
kubernetes cluster like kubernetes like
if you don't know it's a system which
allows you to deploy manage and scale
your localized containerized
applications so actually you can have
your own cloud on top of any existing
clouds as Amazon or Google I don't think
that it's like it's really matters for
you just keep in mind that dusk really
works well with coordinates but you need
to pass through some pain and SQL netis
infrastructure today and the community
is very strong there are already package
managers which doing the same operations
as for example on Ubuntu you have
apt-get install or like when you're
running Mac OS and you need to install
something you running brew install so so
they say same system like Colt helm is
managing and deploying kubernetes
applications like but actually when you
have application as database or and the
website it will install you the database
and all the services as additional
docker images so that's the the
condition told that you can run how to
install and install tasks and actually
everything will magically happen and
everyone is happy by default and
actually they were almost right but we
had to pass through some pain next slide
your goes yeah yeah it was a bit
different
next slide so while passing through the
desk deployment we encountered several
problems which we luckily cracked and
one of the largest problem was actually
that as this does kubernetes
home package was managed by
people who are not very strong in DevOps
operations and modern like kubernetes
set up that chart was really outdated
because it was kept in the same
deployment cycle as all helm official
charts it means that they had to pass
the same quality assurance as really
stable and compliant helm applications
so what we had to tackle that problem so
we made a local fork of the repository
and we had to discover if all these bugs
which we encourage it were already
reported and the check if there are
existing pull requests and so we
collected all the patches from this pull
request and had to apply that locally of
course it's not the ideal way of doing
that operation but it was the only way
how we could resolve and make the system
up and running today that problem is not
relevant anymore because as I've seen
that dusk maintainer
they have their dedicated helm repo and
it's really up to date because like I
checked the latest commits and the
latest changes it's just a few days ago
I guess was the latest committing that
repo so it's really today up to date so
that problem is not luckily it's not
relevant anymore the same problem was
with docker images and today is also
solved latest docker image update
happened 11 days ago next is another
problem with as Jurgis discovered really
nice package to tackle this algorithmic
problems I discovered that that package
is not included by default in people or
docker image and when you are trying to
install it it's actually on Linux it's
tries to compile using requiring GCC to
be installed and some libraries so it
wasn't
we have we wanted like it what it meant
for us that every time when we are
running that job it's actually pulling
the algorithm image docker image and
installs for desk this package and tries
to compile it so it definitely was out
of the scope of our project so I saw
that problem the way that I took this
image and converted into the condo
package I compile this condo packages
and as I already had some experience of
maintaining condor channels and condo
packages for Raspberry Pi so I published
it in my channel and now configuration
is using the precompiled package and
installing it seamlessly without any
kind of the problem next one so of
course I love by default desk workers
they were not beat him up enough like
the configuration was not allocating
enough enough RAM and enough CPU so we
had to play a bit with configuration of
the llamo like ya know it's so help and
kubernetes they keep their configuration
for the services in yemen so we had to
find the optimal parameters how how much
CPU and how much RAM we need for our
workers like so they don't crashing
because of the lack of the RAM but also
that we are not burning the money when
just making these instances up and
running so it took us also a while and
helped us to establish to improve our
soft skills in communicating with DevOps
team like violating us to experiment and
play with kubernetes by killing and
deploying new instances next one
unfortunately we still had like some
several problems but then they were not
like mission critical but could like
optimize our protocols like a bit for
example like every time when we running
this job
expressing all the information about
them add names from App Store and Google
we could coop keep that in some kind of
the cash and not export it every time
for because like it's not the
information which is updating really
frequently but what we discovered that
for that we have to crack the problem
that we need to share that data in from
some cloud some storages or like network
drive attached to every desk worker and
with kubernetes it's possible but not
very straightforward as we used to do
another problem that we did not figure
out how dusk is actually running the
garbage collector because after the job
completed for some reason the desk
workers kept some information in RAM
even though we try to force to delete
these variables and to kill these data
frames so we discovered away that we
just flush all the desk workers after
job ends like dumb dumping all the data
which they are keeping it could be
really critical if the desk if there are
zero any other processes critical for
business running on the same workers but
luckily it's not the case another
problem like not problem like actually
like nice to have optimization now that
we have this machine learning algorithm
machine learning algorithm and duska
actually provides you the way to
distribute different algorithms across
the workers they integrated nicely with
sci-fi and scikit-learn but
unfortunately there is no yet
distributed version of the algorithm
which we are using maybe like they will
add it in the next version because I
already saw some peers and discussions
about adding there
algorithm next one so here's a video of
our last cluster in action and it's a UI
for the scheduler which is distributing
work jobs across all the workers and you
get it just out out of the box and for
us it was very a nice and convenient
convenient way or to understand what is
what is happening like if task workers
really work and how much RAM they
consuming yeah so to summarize we
developed a stream similarity maxing out
algorithm that uses
tf-idf factorization from scikit-learn
dot product notification from sparse dot
top and paralyzation using tasks and
it's also deployed on google kubernetes
engine some of the learnings from this
project are that well you can find an
open-source package for almost anything
in python something I did not point out
enough during the presentation is that a
big part of the speed-up came came with
cleaning up the data to reduce the size
of the data sets or to clean up the app
names before applying the cosine
similarity algorithm and so on well and
of course that there are more than one
solutions solution to a problem and I'm
pretty sure that some of you might
already have ideas of how to do this
differently I would like to thank Uzi
show me and Yago for their feedback and
support while developing this and if you
guys want access to the code just follow
the link of our article towards data
science I will share the presentation
after the the Meetup or you can reach
out to us directly using our contact
details so it's not it's now time up for
quick questions I think thank you guys
hey laptop I should record a clap track
I just made that the end of the video um
so okay thank you for the presentation
we already have some questions and I see
that Guyana has in fact already answered
some of them on the chat yeah so okay
and how do you assess the quality of the
algorithm and kind of related to that I
had a question how how did you like did
you check for false positives how and
and how many did you have like how did
that process look like
yeah so the the whole assessment was
manual so we just take the names the the
results that we come and it's still an
ongoing process this one because there
are a lot of apps in the App Store that
have up names that are very close so by
one letter by two letters difference so
we get very a lot of similarity scores
that are very close to each other in
this case what you can do is start
playing with for example taking the most
popular up so if if one up has like no
downloads which is the case for a lot of
apps then we ignore this one and
workarounds like like this one so
because with the string similarity you
can go up to a point where you take two
different sets of words and you get a
score the logic after it and and what's
what's the app that it may they actually
mean it's it it's it it's one more
interesting a problem to solve yeah okay
so just to clarify so you you when you
said you checked it manually you checked
it manually by looking at like
individual examples or did you actually
manually label a day a test data set and
then test the algorithm on that No
the results you just checked it and
we're like you you eyeballed it and
we're like well ok this looks fine yeah
got it
did you have a look at word embeddings
to vectorize the words oh what do you
mean by word embeddings I am assuming
that the person who asked the question
means we're the beddings like were Tyvek
or glove word embeddings or things like
that
I don't get it if a word is embedded in
what you need maybe up me more yes so
your data set was just individual app
names out of context
yeah right I can actually go to an
example here here so that's what we
receive for example and that's what we'd
like to have that's the be up that we
must it with let's say okay and that's
the score I'm assuming now that the
answer to the question did you look at
where their bearings is no you did not
[Music]
exactly that sort of answers the
question yeah and have you checked out
I'm assuming this is a library called
Feist if a I double s for doing cosine
similarity it's very fast
uh-huh we haven't checked it so I'm not
aware of this and as I said towards the
end I'm pretty sure there are like other
ways of doing it so this is not a
benchmark of finding the fastest method
to solve the problem it's just how we
did it in a production way so we can
keep moving forward with business we
then took all the methods and so on I'm
not even aware of of this library but
I'm happy to check it out and see how it
compares to this it's organization I I
don't know I'm just creating questions
that people say ok this is of the
library like if they I SS this is not a
private chat that you are not
you're talking I always think it's
coming from you so many questions among
this mati I think this is maybe a
question for for Gaia so the presence is
I'm dealing with a similar task step set
up did you compare using processes and
threads do you have any insights for a
beginner
no like I know like what the question is
about no like we try to keep as standard
as we could because we already did
enough customizations and as my goal was
also like to hand over for maintenance
to our DevOps team which is not let's
say like experts in different python
libraries for me also like one of the
goals would be like to make it
maintainable so and we if we apply too
much customizations like it would not
work out for us and again like we
suffered enough making like getting that
system up and running so for us also it
would be like to stop at the point when
it's good enough yeah in my experience
whenever I've used tasks either on
single machines or as a distributed
cluster I've always just said all of the
workers to be single threaded and rely
on the paralyzation happening through
multiple cores but I've never done any
extensive testing on what works if on
some workloads it would be better to use
multiple threads that's just I don't
know I've picked up a habit that
anything involving threads is a bad idea
either I think also like here is worth
mentioning that our bottleneck was not
computing power but distributing data
across workers and joining and
running different operations on the dead
data frame so I would say like we will
mostly stuck with RAM limits then actual
computing power okay there's a there's a
kind of a related question to the whole
task business this is quite a long
questions oh god maybe you want to check
it out on be on the chat window but I'll
read it out anyway how does that help in
monitoring data quality classification
score timings and such what are the
differences between task and airflow
there's actually if you look on the task
documentation there is a page dedicated
specifically to these questions so
that's maybe a good resource for that
the differences between tasks and
airflow specifically since you use
kubernetes do you use additional
monitoring software like Prometheus and
if so how do you work with Prometheus
tasks so as I remember we are not using
like when primitives for monitoring
click on a particular kubernetes cluster
in our cases the standard kubernetes
google kubernetes like google cloud
kubernetes monitoring software was
enough and what like since like way
what's different there that's care flow
like you can check tasks doesn't help in
monitoring in data quality inculcation
score it helps on a crunching huge data
frames with a drop in panda's api
replacement and distributed between like
different workers so when your machine
single machine is not powerful enough
and definitely you won't be able to like
to have like 128 gigabytes ram instance
like i like you're very rich it helps
you to to produce it like with a using
like regular Python code like for as I
remember like for Jurgis it was like
just dropping the replacement like PG
to didi try and even like on his laptop
it was already good enough and did like
significant computational boost because
a distributed between workers and all
stalls and used all the RAM available on
the laptop so files yeah so like in our
case it was like about that pandas
doesn't hit desk it okay answer the
question
yeah so I I had a couple of questions
related to that did you use the adaptive
dash cluster or or did you just bring up
new sort of task clusters as you needed
them no we like we stuck with one a
single like that's cluster we did not
use adaptive one because okay like in in
our case it wasn't needed again yeah
like adaptive one like you can look like
you have Jupiter Jupiter hope you have
like adaptive desk clerks you have like
this huge the kubernetes cluster with
shrinking like or like expanding like or
according to configuration yes like you
can do it but again we don't have so
much data to produce likes to use this
kind of features yeah okay there's
another question difference between desk
and spark again I would refer you to the
ask documentation that's there's a page
and the differences between tasks and
spark specifically from the maintainer
zuv tasks so that's probably the best
resource for that and one final question
for Jurgis and how was the similarity
scored in the ground truth computed how
big is the dataset sorry come again how
how was the similarity score in the
ground truth computed I think that's the
slide where you have the a couple of the
app names listed and the similarity
scores so how is that similarity yeah so
how is that similarity score can cue
and how big is the data set so with
which light are you referring to the
slide where you have the app names
listed this one exactly okay
and will you talking about a specific
example here similarity the similarity
score is just a cosine it can go from 0
to 1 yeah so that's the cosine distance
of the tf-idf vector
yes yes exactly so this is you vectorize
this you vectorize this do the dot
product get the result and then there's
some threshold of like which are using
to cut down yeah all the matches
anything that's a below point 7 is cut
down and then you pick up the highest
one yeah yeah okay like I just wanted to
add one mention here like that case is
very specific like we're talking about
the app names they willed like they're
very short they're using like some weird
words so the regular string matching
like approaches probably could work but
you have to play a lot and in that
particular case like I believe like we
found some kind of the optimal approach
yeah okay very good well then thank you
again to Jurgis and Gaia for the
presentation and answering all the
questions patiently this this is the
time where we would normally